you didn't wreck 1 & 2 with John Webb
alligator wreck 3 you did it by yourself
and has more of an 80s vibe to this one
and more of a comic feel as well so what
influenced you in that I'm not sure I
think directory is part of a tradition
of spanish cinema which comes from
Louisville Langer Luis buñuel this mix
of horror and comedy which is something
that is very very Spanish we have you
know I think it's something is specific
of Spain is there the ability of doing
humor from the most horrific situations
I mean this movie is well the zombies
seem a little bit faster moving bit more
athletic how did you make that decision
well it's because after two films they
got really fit and it was they were
really unstoppable you know they have
been trained for years so who they are
like Usain Bolt or something they are
really really fast now it's because in
each film we have tried to make
different ways of approaching the
zombies of what we wanted to do in this
is that when you turn into a zombie you
preserve the quality the skills you have
when you are while you are a human and
we have this waiters very young athletic
young young boys and girls and they and
they love to jump we didn't want them
just to run but to jump and even to fly
another change we made in this one you
have found footage in it but you also
get more traditional don't you what was
the thinking behind that well I think
it's a mix of things on one hand is that
what we wanted to do with reactor II was
delivering something really different
and really surprising for the audience
and part of it was to tell the story in
a different way of filmmaking going back
to traditional but especially because
the story we wanted to tell I think that
the ideal way to tell it was going back
to a traditional cinematics
but it wasn't that we were trying to
make a statement like BOV sober or
something like that because it's not
that but it was part of that and and you
know I hadn't used a tripod for five
years and I really I'm getting older and
I really need it now there's a comic
book out as well in Spain isn't there
tell me about that and will there be an
english-language version the comic movie
I hope so I hope so we are really really
happy with a comic book because it fills
all the holes in the wreck films you
know we use the comic book to tell the
stories we were not able to fit into the
films it was a terrific experience and I
think we're going to do a new a new a
new version of a new with new stories
and new coming and I hope it gets
translated into English finally what we
expect from wreck apocalypse which will
be chalmers filmed by himself and also
tell me giving you an insight about why
you think there's such a great tradition
at the moment in Spain with horror
movies
yeah well I'm what for sure I know I'm
but I positively know that wreck for is
going to be amazing because Alma's a
great director and I'm not saying that
because it's my friend you know he's
really good brilliant and it's going to
be a great film and it's true that
recently there has been very good
samples of horror films in in Spain and
I think it it comes from when there was
a TV show in Spain called mysterious
paranormal when we were all are my
generation when we were kids and we
watched all the universal hammer
the Vincent Price films we were kids
watching horror movies every week and I
think that something in our brains that
a little seed that is beginning to
blossom and what's next video Paco well
I'm working in a new graphic novel and a
new incoming who because it was such a
great experience working in the comic
book of wreck that I that I'm now
finishing a new one so you know it's
called Dan Friday and it's a vampire
story
you